churches in the state of nevada now have  new covid regulations after a federal  court ruling that just came through  today  they can now have up to 25 percent  capacity  instead of the 50 person total limit  governor steve sislak changed that  directive today after the ruling  calvary chapel in dayton valley had sued  saying  the capacity limit was holding them to a  different standard  than businesses and violated the  constitution  today a federalist appeal court agreed  citing a recent supreme court ruling  that churches  couldn't be treated harsher than other  industries the governor said in a  statement that he was disappointed by  the order  but will follow it and urge people to  practice their religious faith  in a safe manner